e
ma petite lili chéri la maison est
acheté cette fois ci nous avons versé un
acompte et la promesse de vente est
signé nous emménageons le 20 août
arago charvy il est extrêmement heureux
et fier il rêve du matin au soir et me
supplie d'acheter pour une fois sans
regarder à la dépense
tout ce dont j'ai envie pour mon cabinet
de travail 1951 elle à triolet annonce
la nouvelle à sa soeur la voilà
propriétaire avec louis aragon du moulin
de villeneuve un moulin du 12è 13è
siècle une activité meunière jusqu'en
1904 une dizaine de propriétaires de
puits et un coup de coeur pour le couple
d'écrivains on dit souvent que louis
aragon l'a acheté pour elsa triolet lé
russe étrangères et veut lui offrir un
petit coin de terre de france alors
c'est un peu romancée mais c'est aussi
parce que aragon avait eu la suppression
de ses droits civiques
il voulait trouver le calme et la
sérénité 1 pour écrire pour avoir
justement pour fuir un peu paris donc
ici on va rentrer dans l'univers des
lignes on est dans le bureau de louis
aragon aragon c'est un bourreau de
travail et travaille énormément
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont été écrites ici
notamment on peut citer la semaine
sainte parce qu'on voit là tous ces
livres reliés cuir qui ont servi de base
à l'écriture de ce roman
les livres visible lors de la visite ne
sont qu'une petite partie de la
collection des auteurs au détour d'un
escalier un trésor
la partie immergée des ouvrages elsa
triolet et louis aragon posséder près de
trente mille livres
il veut que ce lieu soit un lieu de
recherche donc et c'est pour ça qu'on a
toutes leurs bibliothèques qui est
accessible aux artistes aux chercheurs
qui souhaitent aller plus loin dans les
oeuvres des deux écrivains
donc voilà donc ça c'est un lieu qui vit
et qui
et des oeuvres d'aragon et d'elsa
continue à intéresser énormément
d'universitaires le lieu se fige le 16
juin 1970 date à laquelle elle à triolet
décède louis aragon va légèrement se
détacher du moulin avant de rejoindre
son épouse enterré au coeur du parc
lorsque l à triolet va mourir en 1970
aragon va faire en sorte d'avoir une
dérogation présidentielle pour qu'ils
puissent être enterrés tous les deux ici
disparu en 1982 le journaliste c'est de
la maison à l'état français
géré par une association le moulin
continue aujourd'hui l'ouverture sur la
création contemporaine voulue par louis
aragon
le site organise des expositions des
animations et le parc accueille des
sculptures la maison triolet aragon
accueille chaque année vingt mille
visiteurs dans son parc de près de 6
hectares